dans les centaines de tests que je vous
ai publié il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses ya beaucoup
de smartphones des ordinateurs des
mondes connectés ya pas mal de choses
mais y'a aussi gladio parce que j'adore
le yo je suis un audiophile ça depuis
très longtemps et aujourd'hui je serais
contente pas vous parler d'un casque que
je teste depuis un petit moment qui est
là que je trouve vraiment cool c'est
commencer par la boîte c'est ça la jabra
élite 85 ch vraiment coup très très cool
pas parfait mais pas loin
et j'aime beaucoup c'est un casque alors
il ya plusieurs couleurs moi je sais
quoi que ce soit à ce sont pas j'aime
bien plutôt cool il a vachement point
positif il ya une belle montée en gamme
une belle maîtrise et un beau savoir
faire de jabra là dessus et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant
il vient s'attaquer aux plus grands
notamment la référence dirait un peu du
moment c'est le casque de sony whl xm3
que j'utilise beaucoup donc je connais
parfaitement bien est ce déjà bras n'a
pas à rougir
on va détailler les ponts de regarder
s'il est bien oui non quoi comment ce
qu'ils avaient fait pour vous tout ça
tout ça tout ça enfin tous complets
maintenant
[Musique]
je crois que c'est un peu le truc du
moment le casque à réduction de bruit il
y en a de plus en plus il ya pas mal de
constructeurs qui se met dessus
et pourquoi c'est vrai que c'est bien et
en plus ce un vrai usages c'est à dire
que bien sais pas si c'est votre cas
mais on prend souvent les transports en
commun et il ya beaucoup de nuisances
sonores beaucoup de bruit et l'idée
c'est un petit peu de pouvoir baisser le
volume sonore de ce qu'on va écouter et
scoop un peu l'extérieur ça évite de se
rendre complètement sourd profité d'une
bonne qualité audio d'écouté aux volumes
qu'on soit au moment où on souhaite sans
avoir à subir un peu environnement donc
c'est vraiment intéressant et il ya
effectivement toute cette isolation
actif que de retrouver avec un cast et
halliche brute mais aussi de
l'innovation passive qui viendront
obstrué vos oreilles ça bouge du coup
ils sont passe pas et ce casque life est
un peu les deux enfin il est même
carrément les deux du fn plutôt bien et
ça c'est cool mais avant de vous montrer
ça je commencer par vous parler un peu
de la boîte et du packaging
parce que là dessus sauf que déjà braff
aussi un excellent travail dans la
fabrication réduction de bruit je veux
le jabra élite 85 h
joli point vous regardez moi j'aime bien
le design trouve ça sympa alors les
couleurs choisies on est dans les codes
de jabra ça marche sympa ces dix années
c'est bien ça fait une grosse boîte qui
vous montre un peu tout ce qu'on peut
faire avec j'aime beaucoup
on a vraiment un message qui est très
sympa mais surtout le meilleur se passe
à l'intérieur
le système d'ouverture et est assez cool
on va enlever ce petit capot on à
s'accaparer taille ensuite on vit encore
tiré par là et là ça sourd et là
normalement à l'intérieur pour trouver
ça ressasser là dedans on sort bon ici
une fois plus rien c'était sympathique
et ensuite là vous avez les informations
pour le démarrer il vous dit télécharger
l'application vous explique un peu ce
que vous allez faire et après vous
pouvez venir alors tiré on va le crochet
voilà et là vous avez toutes les
informations de garantie et salomon
c'est une ouverture qui est assez
marrante
ce port un truc de ouf mais c'est assez
marrant parce que voyez vous avez
différentes façons d'ouvrir le paquet
différents axes et puis après vous
arrivez directement la tuque et l'étui
du du casque trop bien me fait penser un
petit peu est dit sony pour entrer ils
n'ont pas inventé la poudre là dessus
mais ça me paraît aussi assez normal
pour trouver le logo jabba qui est là
qui très très sympa blues ouvrait
fermeture sérieuse et bien mais aussi
vous arrivez à l'intérieur c'est doux
c'est molto est ce à dire protéger le
casque vous retrouvez donc votre petite
caste qui à l'intérieur qui du coup bah
écoutez voyez il se plie dont vous
pouvez le mettre un peu comme vous
voulez ça ça je trouve ça cool hein même
si vous n'avez pas ça a voulu mais dans
un état peu plus petits eh bien regardez
ce quelque chose qui va pouvoir se plier
avant pas terminée
porte voix de tous les côtés mais en
tout cas c'est bien mais voyons peu le
bouger pour le plus sûr soit on fait
comme on veut ça c'est vraiment cool et
à l'intérieur tout ce qui est bien c'est
qu'après vous est forcément votre petit
cap pour nous de le recharger ici en usb
c est en hausse mais parce que oui
mesdames et messieurs il va se recharger
ici en usb c'est vous avez aussi ici
votre prise jack parce que oui mesdames
et messieurs vous avez un câble bien sûr
un câble jack est donc ça c'est
vachement bien si vous voulez en
profiter d'une écoute filaire sur de
nombreux appareils c'est très
intéressant et en plus la même cet
adaptateur là pour venir dans les avions
parce que je ne sais pas si vous prenez
souvent l'avion
mais si vous le preniez souvent vous
savez que eh bien vous avez soit ce
système là qui est un peu le système hop
revient net soit ce système là qui est
un peu le système old school soit
système là vous brancher en zinc dont ça
dépend des avions en tout cas c'est bien
vous d'avoir ces accessoires là vous
faites comme vous voulez moi je trouve
ça vachement pratique avec un peu de
métier ça sans kambala tout ça vachement
pratique je trouve ça cool ça marche
bien et puis bon vous allez ça
effectivement pour éviter toute
l'humidité mais voilà les outils
fondamentaux sont là sont présents c'est
cool donc voilà ça je trouve ça très
bien il ya un bon boulot et un beau
packaging a été fait là dessus très beau
boulot bravo djabbar à l'esthétique
connaît mais bien réussi souffle jabra
fin boboul si vous êtes vraiment un côté
un côté matériaux je vous montre ça hop
on se met comme ça regardez là là je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte de
la matière donc il ya vraiment touché un
petit peu un petit peu granuleux un peu
matière qui est très sympa en plus qu'il
est complètement étanche
il est garanti pendant deux ans
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière donc
ça c'est assez exceptionnel c'est cool
vous avez toute une partie
on va essayer de revenir naître toute
une partie coussinage confort qui est là
qui est plutôt bien au niveau de
l'arceau alors ce n'est pas ce qui est
mieux je préfère celui du de sony mais
franchement pour une supporter plusieurs
centaines sans aucun problème c'est sûr
ça cool les indications de l'estate à
l'intérieur il bouge bien vous pouvez le
positionner à voyez vous ouvrez vous le
mettez comme vous le régime micro non
peut-être faire un peu le bazar mais
vous le mettez comme vous voulez et je
trouve ça cool vous pouvez bien
évidemment les tendres le refermer voilà
je trouve intéressant ça a été un beau
travail
tout ce côté un peu mattia vous allez
retrouver la l vachement intéressant les
coussins aussi les petits coussinets
sont sont assez confiants moi je trouve
bien c'est intéressant et en plus ce qui
est cool c'est qu'ils ont de cette
petite forme
il ya une très bien épouser la forme de
vos oreilles en tout cas la forme de mes
oreilles et je sais pas pour tout le
monde c'est bien le cas
bon on l'a déjà symbole du truc
vachement j'ai toute l'isolation facile
donc là déjà jeu à idées mars
ce qui est génial avec ce casque cd vous
le mettez sur votre tête
il sait que vous l'avez mis sur la tête
et tout de suite il s'active et
justement quand vous l'enlevez où vous
dégagez juste les oreilles comme ça il
sait que vous l'avez décalé y met la
pause si vous passez un appel
téléphonique
il va couper micro et pas mal de petites
options qui sont vachement bien et saint
cast qui du coup est intelligent donc ça
j'aime beaucoup je trouve que europe
je possède vraiment intéressant de la
part de jabrane à un confort célian
nebel isolation passive
voilà donc de ce point de vue là dedans
page du club purement extérieur finition
c'est vraiment un cas ce qui n'a pas du
tout à rougir
et il ya vraiment un très très beau
boulot qui est fait là dessus en tout
cas au niveau du produit tout la mise en
service ont pu se fait extrêmement
rapidement donné vous avez quelle charge
et sa part c'est direct le fait de la m
sur les oreilles ça lance vous avez
juste une application je vous la montre
quelques instants qui permet
effectivement bien de le relier à votre
smartphone vous activez le bluetooth tac
vous le reconnaissez il s'active
directement on peut paramétrer les
choses avec l'application c'est
vachement bien c'est pas le plus léger
il fait 296 g
me ben on trouve que le poète assez bien
répartis une phase sur la tête ce n'est
pas absolument aucun problème en plus
vers les petits boutons et ça c'est
vraiment côté un peu génial donc la
droite gauche mais sur la tête comme ça
là vous avez un petit bouton au centre
qu'à faire un plein poste qui va
permettre d'envoyer le de répondre à un
appel de couper un appel de mettre la
musique de l'arrêté vous en douterez la
boule monter le volume vous baisser le
volume vous fait différent et puis là
aussi ça vous pouvez passer au morceau
suivant sous pression enfin bon ça c'est
un grand classique mais par contre ce
qui est vraiment bien c'est que c'est
très intuitif on retrouve tout de suite
grâce à la halle ce petit creux j'ai
dessiné le bouton marche/arrêt les
boutons de volume sont très facilement
identifiable c'est vachement cool là en
plus avaient juste deux petits boutons
un petit bouton ici qui va vous servir
pour activer votre intelligence
artificielle or quand vous de paramétrer
vous avez deux solutions soit vous
paramétrez amazon alexa vous saisissez
votre compte amazon ça marchait
parfaitement bien soit il va utiliser
l'assistant vocal de votre smartphone
série google assistant donc c'est
vraiment pratique que vous soyez sur
android ou sur un os
ça marche parfaitement bien c'est cool
et là vous avez le bouton qui vous
permet de régler votre réduction de
bruit soit pas de réduction de bruit
soit une réduction de bruit active soit
ce qu'ils vont appeler heures flou et
doit pour l'accent qui enrôle écoute de
l'un
heureusement ça va grâce au micro que
vous allez ça permettra d'écouter ce qui
se passe autour de vous donc ça ça peut
être intéressant lorsque vous êtes en
ville pour entendre les bruits des
véhicules autour de lui une application
qui est cool c'est l'application diarra
faisait pouvoir retrouver ici dans
lequel vous allez voir tous vos
paramètres alors l'idée si vous arrivez
dans un paramètre de base qui s'appelle
mon moment qui va être rendront votre
réglages par défaut donc mois par défaut
j'ai activé la réduction proactive vous
pouvez choisir comme l'audi orphelins
comme vous voulez on voit le mono
désactivé vous avez un petit équaliseur
pour moi j'ai monté un petit peu le côté
grave
histoire de moi ajoute un peu de rondeur
que j'écoute des morceaux acoustiques
s'améliore un peu la partie acoustique
d'éditeurs donc ça c'est intéressant
mais ça dépend vraiment le coup dit à
l'écouté vous avez cinq banques de
fréquence vous pouvez régler c'est pas
énorme
ces deux sont des banques qui sont assez
large mais c'est bien que ça et ça
permet effectivement est bien de réguler
je dirais selon vos goûts
donc si vous avez des réglages de
musique par défaut bon allez c'est pas
du truc de ouf enfin voilà ça fonctionne
par contre un truc que je trouve assez
cool sauf que vous revenez sur par
défaut ça vous met votre dernière
réglages
donc là je peux tu te retrouver comme en
gt up je me recaler un petit peu au
dessus je remonte un peu lui un petit
peu lui et j'en trouve exactement les
croyants ce cas j'étais donc si jamais
je ne bouge
eh bien j'ai pas tout foutu en l'air je
le vois ça c'est cool
ensuite ça c'est votre moment par défaut
c'est que c'est votre réglages par
défaut ensuite vous allez pouvoir
choisir un réglage spéciale par exemple
pour les transports en commun là par
exemple via la réduction relative je
veux pas être embêté j'ai mon équaliseur
par défaut je fais comme je veux ça
c'est plutôt cool
lorsqu'à beaucoup de monde et bien vous
pouvez dire soit réduction bruit soit je
vais attendre un petit peu ce qui se
passe je suis dans la rue je marche je
veux vraiment être un petit peu attentif
à ce tournoi je préfère comme ça et
lorsque je suis en privé tout seul j'ai
désactivé son bruit je m'en fiche j'ai
pas une nuisance autour de moi j'aurai
mon équaliseur je fais ce que je n'en
voyais c'est cool vous pouvez vraiment
faire que vous voulez comme vous voulez
donc c'est vraiment intéressant après
vous avez la partie découverte alors il
ya tout cas parti pour la mise à jour
votre logiciel qu'il a pu montrer un
petit peu comment il fonctionne là ça
vous montre les différents boutons
donc c'est un petit peu didactique c'est
très sympa un à-propos qui sort un peu
de faq pourquoi pas mais surtout c'est
la partie la plus intéressante c'est
vraiment celle là et c'est très intuitif
oui vous retrouvez même votre niveau de
batterie de votre casque qui est là donc
très bon boulot une fois de plus la part
de d'habré là dessus je dirais que
maintenant la question principale est
fondamental c'est la partie expérience
audio lorsqu'on a beau avoir une belle
application avoir un beau casque avoir
un beau packaging
mais si derrière le
n'est pas terrible ça marche pas elle
franchement quand je les ai mis sur la
tête pour la première fois je l'écouté
on n'en voit jamais des morceaux que
j'ai l'habitude d'écouter et la belle
qualité je pourrais car en fait le truc
qui est intéressant c'est effectivement
déjà comme vous êtes isolé vous n'êtes
pas embêtés vous n'êtes pas obligé de
mettre fort le casque faisait pas gêné
par l'environnement et vous avez une
très belle restitution que je trouve au
final assez neutre je vous dis j'ai
monté un petit peu les grappes à ce que
j'écoutais dernièrement des morceaux
acoustiques à la guitare avouer que ça
ça ronronne un peu plus mais vous le
mettez plaçe plat pour moi vous avez le
meilleur rendu les équaliseur qui sont
fournis à l'intérieur et les différents
paramètres paroles sages moi je trouve
ça pas très pas terrible resté sur du
flat sauf si vous avez quelque chose
d'un peu particulier que vous voulez
monter soit de l'aigu pour récupérer un
petit peu de un petit peu cymbales des
choses comme ça mais sinon je trouve ça
bien comme il est là il est bien
équilibré vous retrouvez un spectacle
assez juste quelle que soit la bande de
fréquence cossure sur des choses un peu
plus grave sur des bases qui vont rhône
et saône est parti un peu médium sur des
parties un peu un peu de champ sur de la
voix ou même sur des aigus pour
récupérer tous les bruits de cymbales
pour moi c'est vraiment juste et précis
je trouve qu'un beau boulot qui est
flatteur on n'est peut-être pas aussi
bon que ce qu'on pourrait retrouver sur
le sony double dash nixon 3e tête
manquée des fois peut-être que les
facettes
le temps n'est pas forcément le bon je
dirais pas un peu brouillon parce que
c'est pas vrai c'est pas brouillon du
tout mais peut-être un peu moins précis
sur certains moments mais c'est du point
de détail et je trouve ça vraiment
passionnant parce qu'il ya un très beau
boulot alors tous que soit créé ta place
tu sais que vous n'avez pas la haute
résolution n'avait pas de là à grèzes là
dessus que vous n'allez pas à voir ce
qui va être le plus au top mais déjà
comme il est là si vous voulez profiter
d'une belle qualité audio vous avez un
produit qui est vraiment bien
le son est vraiment très juste et ça je
vous dis j'écoutais plein de styles
différents j'ai écouté du métal j'ai
écouter du rock j'écoutais des balades
j'écoutais du jazz j'ai écouté de
l'électro vous pouvez toujours réajusté
en fonction de l'écho à l'isr même si
bon je sais pas c'est parce que je vous
recommande
mais je trouve que le son est juste la
qualité est bonne et jabra continue de
monter en gamme et il arrive dans la
cour des grands il se met en face un des
meilleurs du marché sur des casques à
réduction de bruit grand public
et franchement ils ont absolument rien à
envier si ce n'est des petits points de
détail aux plus grands et je pauvres
dans les années à venir et donc aussi
avec des propositions encore plus haut
niveau et ce qui est vraiment bien et ce
qu'on voit c'est la volonté de la gamme
de se positionner sur ce marché qui
marche bien qui est intéressant qui dure
parce que concurrentiel
jabra ce mec là tu sais courageux et
pour le coup la copie vraiment bien
réussi puisque l'autonomie assez
intéressante jabra nous annonce 36
heures alors j'ai pas mesuré à la minute
et au point de détail près mais
franchement je pense que les 30
histoires là dessus vous les avez en
plus la taille sans s'imaginer vous êtes
à court de batterie et bien vous lui
mettez un petit quart d'heure de
recharge est parti pour 5 heures musique
là vous êtes tranquille et si vous
voulez de recharger complètement il vous
faudra deux heures trente
bon la recharge complète vous le
branchez la nuit quelque chose près vous
êtes tranquilles votre parti 2h30 ça
passe très vite vous mettez les presque
déjà un bon film que vous regardez sans
casque et bien vous pouvez partir
longtemps donc si vous faites des
trajets longs des trajets d'avion et
bien un casque comme ça vous pourrez
l'utiliser dans ces conditions ne serait
ce que par la réduction de bruit c'est
vachement intéressant je pense notamment
w/h mix m 3 de sony vous allez voir une
différence sont le fait d'avoir de la
haute résolution et là vous l'avez pas
bon c'est sûr après bon il ya une petite
différence de prix autre point de
différence sur le double avec sam 3
d'impôt du logiciel vous allez pouvoir
lorsque vous êtes en avion pouvoir vous
calé par rapport à la pression
atmosphérique est là dessus vous ne
pouvez pas mais une fois de plus c'est
du point de détail aura peut-être plus
le comparer wmx n 2 qui est le modèle
précédent peut-être de chez sony
à côté de ça vous avez aussi toute la
question de la latence 1
nous tous 5.0 vous avez une petite
latence elle existe elle est là lorsque
vous allez vouloir regarder une série ou
un film mais extrêmement minime
moi j'ai regardé des séries interview tu
bien évidemment j'ai rêvé de série sur
netflix avec ça m'a pas dérangé ça ne
pose pas de problème c'est pas
problématique c'est du point détails ça
pourrait effectivement de plus tu l'as
si vous voulez utiliser en version
bluetooth et que cette petite latence
vous dérange pas vraiment mini
d'entraînement elle est vraiment minime
donc bon pour moi ce n'est pas
problématique
eh bien ça marchera si toutefois vous
dites ah ça m'embête et bien ce moment
avoue passer en jack ça marche et
beaucoup vous l'aurez pas du tout bon
alors tout ça c'est bien beau mais qu'en
est il du prix j'ai tout là-dessus il
est annoncé un peu moins de 300 euros au
prix catalogue
l'ours a lancé à 299 euros 99 points
très précis après vous trouvez un peu
moins cher
j'ai différents tarifs chez boulanger à
285,6 amazon autour de 260 euros chez
son vidéo 289 fnac darty c'est à peu
près pareil 280 quelques et hébreu ne
sait plus trop d'ailleurs si vous
intéresse vous aimez il ya des liens en
bas dans la description pour trouver aux
meilleurs tarifs ont mis la profession
voilà moi je trouve intéressant je
trouve bien alors vous avez sur votre
bluetooth d'une portée de 10 mètres vous
baladez vous êtes tranquille il y coule
c'est pour moi un casque
si vous voulez rentrer dans la réduction
de bruit elles trouvaient autour des
halles et 260 euros
vous avez vous avez un bon prix
peut-être un peu moins dans les temps à
venir peut-être on verra une pour moi
vous arrivez sur un projet qui vraiment
coûté vraiment bien qu est bien fini ils
sont sur un produit extrêmement aboutie
un produit qui est beau moi je le trouve
bien si vous voulez un produits
différenciants si vous ne voulez pas un
produit de voix si vous voulez pas un
produit de sony si vous voulez un
premier déjà bras si vous aimez la
marque danoise
et si vous voulez vous faire plaisir
avec un casque est aujourd'hui de bonne
qualité avec une belle application de
belles finitions très facile très
intuitif et bien là pour moi vous avez
un produit qui est vraiment bien et
voilà je trouve alors je vous dis ça
c'est un parti très personnel je trouve
intéressante tu ne vois pas de jabra tu
me disais midi tout ça non pas du tout
moi je le trouve intéressant 29,5 à skis
déjà lorsque vous le posez comme ça ça
fait presque un peu casque de chantier
sa coupe et là il dit batterie médium
connecte il voyait donc il reconnaît
tout de suite il se connecte
automatiquement ça je trouve ça génial
ne serait ce que pour ça c'est un tel
gadget ne trouve ça vraiment à 100 dites
moi comment vous le trouvez ce de jabra
élite 85
hs qu'il vous fait de l'oeil un petit
peu ou pas du tout qu'est ce que vous en
pensez par rapport aux vous dire aux
poids lourds du marché dans cette gamme
de
de produits notamment le sony wf 1000x
n3 comment vous trouvez
est ce que vous le trouver intéressant
ce qu'ils peuvent ou tenter ce qu'il
vous a déjà tenté ce que vous l'avez
est-ce que vous avez d'autres produits
de jabra et puis est-ce que celui à peu
vous tentez vous ne marquez tout ça en
commentaire et si vous avez des
questions allez-y paf on envoie les
commentaires on l'est tous à s'entraider
répondre c'est ça va comme ça c'est cool
je vous embrasse souffre de gros bisous
et puis on repart très prochainement
d'audio on va parler du temps des
casques beats que j'ai honte est
actuellement c'est une autre histoire
mais ça c'est dans quelques jours donc
abonnez-vous dès maintenant à bientôt
ciao